today I'm going to be showing you how to
use the skills progress report in the
administrator dashboard and the Khan
Academy platform
this is going to be a great tool in
order for you to support your teachers
in differentiation in their classrooms
you can share this data with specific
teachers
plcs or Department chairs so once you
log into Khan Academy go head over to
the left hand panel and you can click on
the skills progress tab once you click
on that tab the screen that you see
before you will pop up on your screen
this report has many filters so I'm
going to walk you through each one of
them so you can see how this can fit
your needs so the first is a date range
there's a drop down menu you can choose
from today the last seven days the last
30 days or a custom range maybe you want
to pick the first semester or the first
six weeks or nine weeks of a of a
semester so I have chosen May 4th
through September 26th you can pick the
Khan Academy course of your choice I
have chosen algebra 1. you can pick one
school or many schools for this example
I'm going to just choose one school you
can choose multiple grades the district
course
and the teacher or multiple teachers
so once you have all your filters in
place you can go ahead and hit the blue
apply button and wait for the report to
load
once the report has loaded there will be
two additional drop down menus that
appear there's a unit view or a combined
View and then you can choose how you
want to see the report by skill level or
number of students so I have picked the
number of students high to low and then
I'm going to pick the unit review so I
can see the specific units and the
skills in that unit
so as you can see in bold letters on the
top of each chart there is the unit and
then and within that unit it tells you
there are seven skills
over to the right you see the skill
levels the darkest purple is the most
mastered and the lightest is attempted
once you look at each skill they're
listed in bold above each bar and the
common core standards are right next to
it so I'm going to look for the lightest
purple and the first one I see is
combining like terms with negative
coefficients and distribution
so I'm going to click on this and I see
that there's three students Jason Carla
and Chelsea that may need some more
support but I see that students seem to
be very successful
in equivalent expressions
so you want to do your comparison you
may want to look at individual teachers
or you may want to compare teachers that
teach the same skill to see where we
need to make changes in teaching that
specific skills to students or where we
may need intervention remediation or
acceleration
so the best thing that you can do is
either take a screenshot and share with
your teachers or use the CSV export that
is right up on top or the blue download
Arrow so that you can export this report
and share it with the teachers that need
the information
if you need more support on this skills
progress data please contact your
District success manager and they'll be
more than happy to give you some more
support and tips on how to use this with
teachers